we can sometimes be so modest about our
power to know what might be good for
others or ourselves we forget it might
be possible to hazard a few
generalizations about what constitutes
an emotionally healthy childhood
it can't be pure idiosyncrasy or good
luck there are distinct themes and goals
to identify with a map of optimal
development in mind we could more
clearly appreciate where dislocations
begin what we have to be grateful for
and what there is to regret at a
collective level we would have more of a
sense of what there is to achieve to
generate a more emotionally privileged
and therefore slightly saner world in
the course of an emotionally healthy
childhood we could expect some of the
following to occur someone will put
themselves profoundly at our service if
as adults we have even a measure of
mental health it is almost certainly
because when we were helpless tiny
infants there was a person to whom we
essentially are our lives who pushed
their needs to one side for a time in
order to focus wholly on our own they
interpreted what we could not quite say
they guessed what might be a lling us
they settled and consoled us they kept
the chaos and noise at bay and cut the
world up into manageable pieces for us
they did not all the while ask that we
thank them understand them or show them
sympathy they didn't demand that we
inquire how their days went or how they
were sleeping at night they weren't much
they treated us like royalty so that we
would later on be able to submit to the
rigors and humiliations of an ordinary
life this temporarily one-sided
relationship
guaranteed our eventual ability to form
a two-sided kind we may think of egoists
as people who have grown sick from too
much love but the opposite is rather the
case an egoist is someone who is not yet
had their fill self-centeredness has to
have a clean run in the early years if
it isn't to haunt and ruin
the later ones the so called narcissist
is simply Abba nighted soul who's not
had a chance to be inordinately and
unreasonably admired at the start in an
emotionally healthy childhood someone is
on hand to put the best possible spin on
our behavior we're given the benefit of
the doubt
we're assessed by what we might one day
be not by exactly what we are right now
someone is kind a harsh judge might for
example say that we were
attention-seeking our caregiver imagines
that what we most stand in need of is
probably a hug and some encouraging
words we might have acted rather meanly
our caregiver adds that we must in the
background have been feeling a bit
threatened it looked as if we were
negligent the caregiver remembers that
tiredness could have had a lot to do
with it a carer constantly searches
beneath the surface for a more
sympathetic set of explanations they
help us to be on our own side to like
ourselves and therefore eventually not
to be too defensive about our own flaws
whose existence we grow strong enough to
accept in a good childhood the
relationship with our caregiver is
steady consistent and long-term we trust
that they will be there tomorrow and the
day after they aren't volatile or
fragile they are almost boringly
predictable and happy to be taken for
granted as a result we develop a trust
in relationships that spread throughout
our life we're able to believe that
what's gone well once can go well again
and let such an expectation govern our
choice of adult partners we aren't
mesmerised by people who are offhand and
unreliable
we don't relish being punished we can
pick out candidates who are kind and
nurturing and don't judge them as weak
or deficient for being so and if trouble
strikes with our kindly partners we
don't panic anxiously or avoidant lis
turn away we can confidently set about
trying to repair a love we know we
deserve in an emotionally healthy
upbringing we aren't always required to
be wholly good boys or girls
we're allowed to get furious and
sometimes a bit revolting at points are
say absolutely not and because I feel
like it the adults know their own flaws
and do not expect a child to be
fundamentally better than they are we do
not have to comply at every turn to be
tolerated we can let others see our
shadow sides this period of freedom
prepares us one day to submit the
demands of society without having to
rebel in self-defeating ways rebels
being at heart people who had to obey
too much too early we can knuckle down
and toe the line when it's in our
long-term interest to do so at the same
time we're not overly coward or
indiscriminately obedient either we find
a sound middle point between slavish
compliance on the one hand and
self-destructive defiance on the other
in the emotionally healthy home our
carer isn't jealous of or competitive
with us they can allow themselves to be
overtaken and superseded they have had
their moment in the limelight or else
having it elsewhere beyond the family
they can be proud rather than rival hrus
of the achievements of the usually
same-sex child it doesn't all need to be
about them the good carer isn't overly
ambitious on the child's behalf they
want them to do well but for their own
sake in their own way there's no
particular script the offspring has to
follow to be loved that child isn't
required to support the carers phrased
self-belief or to burnish their image in
the eyes of the world in the emotionally
healthy upbringing the child learns that
things which break can be fixed plans
can go awry but new ones can be made you
can fall over and dust yourself off the
carer models for the child how to calm
down plough on and remain hopeful a
voice of resilience originally external
becomes the way the child learns to
speak to themselves there are
alternatives to panic the ship will
endure the storm and make it back to
harbor it's safe enough to go outside
and explore there aren't dangers at
every turn
we can make little forays at first and
come back for reassurance only to return
for another longer journey of
exploration we can take risks
importantly plenty goes wrong in the
emotionally healthy childhood
no one has staked their reputation on
rendering the whole thing perfect the
carer does not see it as their role to
remove every frustration they ensure it
that a lot of good comes from having the
right manageable kind of friction
through which a child develops their own
resources and individuality in contact
with a bearable disappointment the child
is prompted to create at their own
internal world in which they can dream
hatch fresh plans self-soothe and build
up their own resources the good carer
isn't the child can see either entirely
good or wholly bad and so isn't worthy
of either idealization or denigration
the child accepts the faults and virtues
of the carer with melancholy maturity
and gratitude and thereby by extension
becomes ready to accept that everyone
they like will be a mixture of positive
and negative
they won't as adults fall deeply in love
and then grow furious at the first
moment of letdown they have a realistic
sense of what can be expected of life
alongside another good enough human
sobering Lee despite all our advances in
technology and material resources we are
not much more advanced in the art of
delivering emotionally healthy
childhoods than previous generations the
number of breakdowns in authentic lives
and broken souls shows no marked signs
of decline we are failing to offer one
another tolerable childhoods not because
we are evil or indifferent but because
we still have so far to go before we
know how to do that most apparently
simple yet infinitely complicated of
things love the dark truths in our book
things you should never tell children
may not be suitable for children but can
offer solace humor and relief to the
older ones a mother
if you liked this film please subscribe
to our channel and click the Bell icon
to turn on notifications